irait sans souci d' amélie billon le
guennec et coralie sudo chez epsilon
jeunesse iris n'aime pas les tracas
quand il arrive devant sa porte elle les
envoie promener
non non et non n'insistez pas ses tracas
ne me sont pas destinés je vous dis que
je ne veux pas de souci un bon coup de
balai et les voilà chez le voisin d'à
côté sans voisin monsieur jasmin ne
sachant plus quoi faire de ces
encombrants les a enterrés mais voilà
qu'ils ont poussé il a essayé de jeter
ses tracas à la poubelle mais ils sont
revenus de plus belle quel désastre
devant sa fenêtre
monsieur jasmin est déboussolée et ne
sait plus quoi faire
les soucis ne cesse de l'importuner
et il en a par dessus la tête de la
machine ac qui s'arrêtent du pot tombé
sur sa tête et de la terrible tempête
qui s'est abattue sur son toit monsieur
jasmin est devenu la risée du quartier
les enfants se pressent devant sa case
pour voir ce qui va lui arriver
quelques-uns n'hésite pas à provoquer
certains tracas monsieur jasmin pourrait
peut-être à son tour faire passer les
ennuis de l'autre côté
mais voilà ils n'osent pas c'est comme
ça monsieur jasmin fouille un peu
partout pour voir s'il n'existe pas un
autre moyen de s'en débarrasser sos
souci abandonné cuisinez vos soucis
selon vos envies
lotion anti souci avoir de la chance
points comme dans la case d'à côté irish
en du matin au soir
arroser les fleurs de son jardin et
remercie le soleil de briller pour elle
mais en y regardant de plus près iris
fini par s'apercevoir que nous tout
n'est pas au mieux chez son voisin
la maison est barricadé pour éviter les
dangers les mauvaises herbes ont envahi
le jardiner et les fleurs
mais de soleil n'arrive plus à pousser
et voilà iris ne voit plus la vie en
rose un souci vient d'entrer par ici
auraient-elles vécu toutes ces années
sans se soucier de ce qui peut se passer
à côté iris en une désagréable sensation
l'envahir
bien décidé à réparer les malheurs se
met elle s'en va sonner chez son voisin
monsieur jasmin iris est surprise de
voir la case ainsi aménagés fer à cheval
trèfle à quatre feuilles et autres porte
bonheur orne un bel intérieur
bonjour je suis venu voir si je pouvais
vous aider à régler certains de vos
tourments de fil en aiguille monsieur
jasmin lui raconte les coups de balai
les soucis arrivée par paquet et
l'impossibilité de les enlever
il repousse à chaque fois et je ne sais
pas par où commencer
iris approche et examine attentivement
les soucis de monsieur jasmin rien de
bien grave mais elle a le coeur serré
elle n'a rien vu rien entendu pendant
toutes ces années
bien trop occupé à regarder le bout de
son nez lui vient alors une idée
ensemble iris et monsieur jasmin
accrocheront les soucis à des ballons et
les laits seront s'envoler ils seront
plus légers aussitôt dit aussitôt fait
quelques garnements et c'est à l'aide de
fléchettes d'atteindre les ballons c'est
peine perdue il va falloir cultiver
autre chose dans ce jardiner monsieur
jasmin eris retroussent leurs manches
ratisse creuse est enfoui dans la terre
de belles graines coloré puis autour
d'un bon café ils se mettent à discuter
des semaines ont passé le jardin de
monsieur jasmin est méconnaissable
le brave homme peut désormais profiter
du soleil il sait qu'au moindre petit
problème il pourra compter sur sa
nouvelle amie tiens cela sent le brûlé
iris tu veux tu que je t'aide à cuisiner
le que rafistolé la confiance retrouvée
il se pourrait bien que de petits
bonheurs est envie de
nir s'épanouir définitivement par ici